[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
d'association avec TV 78 depuis 1997 la
ville de Bois-d'Arcy est jumelée avec la
ville de Michelle en Allemagne quels
sont les objectifs du jumelage comment
les deux villes font perdurer le
jumelage et l'amitié franco-allemande et
est-ce que le jumelage a encore un sens
aujourd'hui pour en parler avec nous je
suis au jour je suis pardon avec Nadine
miroschnikov vice-présidente du comité
de jumelage Bois d'Arcy Michel bonjour
bonjour
Alors Michel est une ville allemande
située dans la région de Sall and salt
qui compte pardon environ 10 000
habitants comment le jumelage entre
Bois-d'Arcy et la ville allemande est
née qu'est-ce qu'il y a inspiré ce
jumelage alors tout au départ je crois
que c'était une
un vrai échange une volonté de partager
entre les écoles allemandes et les
écoles françaises
et de partager entre les élèves du
collège donc ça a été vraiment au départ
[Musique]
ce sont des professeurs qui est
d'allemand et de Français qui ont
travaillé ensemble et qui ont commencé à
faire poindre ce cette idée du match et
après comment est-ce que ça a évolué
parce que les villes ont souhaité l'une
et l'autre c'était aussi bien bois
d'article Michel on souhaitait que ça
s'étend à tous les citoyens de la ville
et pas seulement au collégien donc
maintenant c'est une vraie ambition
d'avoir cette
collaboration entre
citoyens des deux communes et des
associations surtout donc aussi bien les
citoyens que les associations de ces
villes avec des matchs de foot des
alors eux nous montrent ce qu'ils savent
notamment on a eu plusieurs fois des
équipes de vélo acrobatique qui sont
d'Allemagne qui sont venus qui faisaient
des choses
[Musique]
sur l'éducation ça se fait plus d'un
point de vue peut-être personnel en fait
les échanges sur l'environnement il y a
eu des projets sur des jardins par
exemple qui ont été mis en place des
mais c'est surtout
un échange culturel et familial c'est
surtout ce point-là avec évidemment les
familles ben c'est les parents les
grands-parents les enfants c'est toutes
les générations confondues elle résume
là j'offre la possibilité de mettre en
place des échanges simplifiés entre
entre les élèves on l'a un petit peu
évoqué ces échanges ont été initiés dans
votre cas en 1992 donc un tout petit peu
avant la signature
un échange entre les élèves alors en
fait c'est pas c'est rarement des élèves
c'est souvent un ou deux élèves qui est
reçu par une famille et qui va avoir une
activité alors soit scolaire soit
extra-scolaire pour pendant un certain
temps dans la ville de Muchel ou dans la
ville de Bois-d'Arcy donc je peux vous
donner des exemples par exemple il y a
Barbara qui est venu qui habitait dans
Bois-d'Arcy et qui travaillait à la
bibliothèque pendant 3 mois et c'est
vrai que quelques années plus tard ben
elle parle toujours très bien le
français et de la même manière il y a
d'autres des jeunes de Michel qui sont
venus en France donc mais il y a aussi
des jeunes de Bois-d'Arcy qui sont
partis à muchen et qui de ce fait là en
perfectionné leur allemand et c'est vrai
que c'est une très bonne occasion quand
on vit dans une famille et dans un
environnement dans une ville allemande
où tout est en allemand la prononciation
et l'amélioration de la langue est
fulgurante quoi alors justement c'est
l'objectif finalement principal de ces
échanges c'est de d'apprendre une une
langue parce que en général les cours à
l'école sont parfois un peu barbant
selon plusieurs jeunes là c'est vraiment
l'occasion d'apprendre sur le terrain de
pratiquer en même temps de découvrir une
agriculture alors c'est c'est vrai qu'on
découvre une nouvelle culture parce que
on ne vit pas tout à fait pareil par
exemple on découvre que le petit
déjeuner ça se prend pas dans des
assiettes mais sur des petites planches
en bois parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
charcuterie et de fromage donc c'est un
petit détail que qui fait que ben c'est
pas tout à fait comme en France mais
quand on est dans le pays il y a surtout
tous les idiomatismes et les phrases
qu'on ne trouve pas
quand on traduit directement et donc
c'est cette
approche de la Hollande qui est très
différente et pour les jeunes c'est non
seulement de connaître une famille de
connaître un pays de connaître une
langue de connaître une manière de
manger une manière de se distraire une
main c'est pas du tout la même chose on
a beaucoup quand même de différence même
si on est très proche justement de la
jeunesse est-ce que vous mettez des
actions en place pour sensibiliser les
élèves et les jeunes en règle générale à
l'amitié franco-allemande alors ça
dépend il y a plusieurs niveaux
c'est-à-dire que au des écoles
maternelles on a la chance d'avoir
certaines personnes qui parlent bien
l'allemand des enseignants des
directeurs d'écoles qui parlent
l'allemand donc ça facilite grandement
cette sensibilisation donc avec des
chansons avec des couleurs
et de ce fait là on il y a des objectifs
qui sont tenus de la même manière à
Michel il y a aussi dans les jardins
d'enfants ils font aussi des des choses
sur la France sur les couleurs de la
France sur les habitudes de la France
donc en fait c'est très partagé vous
rencontrez vos homologues allemands au
moins une fois par an en 2021 vous y
êtes allé lors de la fête nationale
d'Allemagne qu'est-ce que vous faites
pendant ces échanges entre ces deux
comités alors pendant longtemps on avait
au moins deux échanges par an maintenant
on en a plus qu'un l'année dernière donc
quand on a été ça a été un séjour un peu
plus long que d'habitude parce que
d'habitude on parle vendredi matin et on
revient le dimanche soir donc il y a
beaucoup de transport et on a vraiment
qu'une vraie journée et deux
demi-journées disons mais alors là comme
c'était la fête nationale allemande et
il faut savoir qu'en Allemagne chaque
année c'est une des régions qui est à
l'honneur et qui va recevoir
des spectacles des expositions et le
chancelier allemand qui ferait un beau
discours là ça a été Angela merkels et
donc c'est intéressant de voir
cette manifestation particulière et nous
avons eu la chance que cette année les
dernières la manifestation c'est
produite disons dans une ville qui
s'appelle haleu et qui était tout proche
de Michel donc on a voulu absolument en
profiter donc il y a eu des événements
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait une belle
exposition qui présentait toutes les
provinces y compris Berlin de
l'Allemagne et donc où on a pu avec
plaisir goûter des spécialités écouter
des chansons des musiques particulière
voir des aussi bien de la science que de
la technologie que de l'environnement
que de la forêt de toutes les régions
d'Allemagne avec des explications et
même on a eu le plaisir de voir des
Allemands qui parlaient vraiment bien
français qui pouvaient nous expliquer
très clairement ce qu'il faisait dans
leur région et alors en janvier une
soirée est organisée sur les 60 ans du
traité de l'Élysée l'occasion pour vous
de faire participer les maternelles
puisqu'ils chanteront est-ce que
l'amitié franco-allemande doit être
justement inculqué dès le plus jeune âge
je pense que quel que soit l'amitié mais
déjà apprendre que si quelqu'un est
différent ce n'est pas pour autant qu'il
est notre adversaire et je crois que dès
l'enfance il faut vraiment multiplier au
maximum la possibilité d'avoir la
diversité et notamment pour l'Allemagne
c'est une proposition qui est faite bon
en région parisienne je pense que cette
diversité dans certains
communes elle est assez flagrante donc
il faut justement faire l'éducation de
pouvoir faire en sorte que bien souvent
je crois que les enfants de d'un très
jeune âge ne font pas la différence
entre son voisin quel que soit sa
couleur ou sa langue et c'est tant mieux
et il faudrait que ça perdure jusqu'à
l'âge adulte en fait c'est ça notre
objectif alors après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale le jumelage franco-allemand
avait un sens très fort et transmettait
un message important la paix entre les
deux nations et ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
estimez que ces jumelages sont encore du
sens alors c'est un sens au niveau
culturel et linguistique certes sportif
gastronomique disons je pense que et
c'est ce que j'ai lu dans un
compte-rendu d'une
d'une enquête qui a été faite jusqu'à
présent les jumelages étaient
considérées comme un lien très fort pour
éviter la guerre et depuis et c'était en
première position dans les
interrogatoires interrogations qu'on
faisait et
les résultats de cette enquête qui a été
peut-être d'ailleurs pas la Commission
européenne et je crois que depuis deux
ou trois ans la Commission européenne a
noté que cet aspect évité la guerre
n'est plus en première position par
rapport à ces échanges entre ville merci
beaucoup Nadine mirochnikov d'avoir été
avec nous sur sensation je rappelle que
vous êtes la vice-présidente du comité
de jumelage Bois d'Arcy Michel pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site bois d'arcy.fr et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]